so most people don't believe that
climate change is a hoax so they believe
that there is an increase there's a
global warming of a few degrees in The
Next Century and then maybe debate about
what the number of the degrees is
and do most people believe that it's
human caused at this time in in in this
history of discussion or conscience so
is that the center still like is there
still the debate on this Yale University
the climate communication group there
for like 13 years has done this six
Americas study where they've charted
pretty carefully and ways that I really
find useful
what people believe and we could talk
about the word belief in the context of
science too but and they've identified
kind of six kinds of us there's from
dismissive to alarmed and with lots of
bubbles in between I think some of those
bubbles in between are mostly disengaged
people who don't really deal with the
issue and they've shown adrift for sure
there's much more majority now at the
alarmed or or engaged uh bubbles then
it's just the dismissive bubble does a
durable like with vaccination and all
lots of other issues there's a durable
never anything
belief group but on on the reality that
humans are contributing to climate
change most Americans when you're asked
ask them and it also depends on how you
write your survey you know I think I
think there's a component globally I
mean when you when you ask around I mean
and and this is you know if you hear the
story from the media of 20 years of
course that's what you'll believe and it
also happens to be true all right that
is what the sign I I think you know it's
perhaps worth saying and it's a little
depressing that you always have to say
but I think it's worth saying that I
think we both really do accept you know
the climate panel uh science and you
know there's absolutely global warming
it is an issue uh and it's probably just
worthwhile to get it out of the world
it's an issue and it's caused by humans
it's caused by humans yeah okay but
vulnerability the losses
that are driven by climate-related
events still predominantly are caused by
humans but on the ground it's where we
build stuff where we settle Pakistan
in 1960 I just looked these data up
there were 40 million people in Pakistan
today there are 225 million and a big
chunk of them are still rural they live
in the floodplain of the amazing Indus
River which comes down from the
Himalayas extraordinary 5000 year
history of Agriculture there but when
you put 200 million people
In Harm's Way and this doesn't say
anything about the bigger questions
about oh shame on Pakistan for having
more people it just says the reality is
the losses that we see in the news
are and and the science finds this even
though there's a new weather attribution
group it's a WX risk on Twitter
this does pretty good work on
how much of what just happened was some
tweak in the storm from global warming
from CO2 changing weather
but and the media glom on to that as I
did you know in the 80s 90s 2000s
but the reports also have a section on
by the way the vulnerability that was
built in this region was a was a big
driver of of loss so discriminating
between loss
change in
what's happening on the ground and
changing the climate system
is never solely about CO2 in fact
Lawrence Bower
um
has for I first wrote on his work in
2010 in the New York Times And basically
in 2010 there was no sign in the data of
climate change driving disasters
the climate change is up here disasters
are on the ground they depend on how
many people are in the way how much
stuff you built in the way and so far
we've done so much of that so fast in
the 20th century particularly
that it completely dominates it makes it
hard impossible to discriminate how much
of that disaster
was from the change in
weather from global warming so a
function of
uh greenhouse gases
to human suffering is is unclear that's
and that's very much in our control
theoretically I mean the the point I
think is is exactly right that you know
if you look at uh hurricane Ian that
went through Florida you have a
situation where Florida went from what
600 000 houses in uh 1940 to 17 million
houses sorry 10 million houses so uh so
17 times more
over uh what a period of 80 years of
course of course you're gonna have one
yeah yeah you're going to have lots more
damage and many of these houses now been
built on you know places where you
probably shouldn't be building and and
so I think uh a lot of scientists are
very focused on saying can we measure
whether global warming had an impact
which is an interesting science question
I think it's it's very implausible that
eventually we won't be able to say it
has an impact but the real question it
seems to me is if we actually want to
make sure that people are less harmed in
the future
what are the levers that we can control
and it turns out that the CO2 lever uh
doing something about climate is an
incredibly difficult and slightly
inefficient way of trying to help these
people in the future whereas of course
zoning making sure that you have better
housing
rules what is it uh regulations uh that
that you maybe you know don't have
people building in the flash flood
lately what was it called flash flood
alley Alleyway yeah it's it's just
simple stuff and and because we're so
focused on this one issue we sort of it
it almost feels uh sacrilegious to to
talk about these other things that are
much more in our power and that we can
do something about much quicker and that
would help a lot more people so I I
think this is uh this is going to be a
large part of the whole conversation you
know yes climate is a problem but it's
not the only problem and there are many
other things where we can actually have
a much much bigger impact at much lower
cost maybe we should also remember those